[Musik]
der hat zehn sie
überall auf der welt
und gleicht
rund um die uhr
filmen kameras
packende
extrem ruhig bleibt ruhig
furchterregende
naturphänomene was sollen wir tun guck
dir das an man ist wie gelähmt
es gibt kein entkommen
das ist reality tv sie glauben sie
kennen das wetter diese experten
erklären was wirklich passiert das
wasser fließt in den wirbel mit
den spektakulärsten wetter videos der
welt
extreme wetterbedingungen machen im
winter besonders oft probleme
das wetter spielt verrückt wind schnee
geringe sichtweite
wenn die temperaturen fallen kann der
harmlose tagesausflug schnell zum
überlebenskampf werden
april 2015 an der südseite des mount
everest beginnt die bergsteiger saison
im basislager fällt am vormittag
leichter frühlings schnee
die erde bebt bis plötzlich ein grollen
den berg erschüttert mit dem handy fängt
ein bergsteiger das erdbeben der stärke
7,8 1
mit sowas hatte niemand dort gerechnet
aufgrund platten tektonischer
verschiebungen kommt es in dieser gegend
häufig zu erdbeben und dieses löst eine
lawine aus
[Musik]
nicht zu fassen guck dir das an
sollen wir ins zelt
es herrscht völliges chaos schnee
felsbrocken und geröll rauschen den berg
runter
die bergsteiger werfen sich in ihrem
zelt auf den boden
im mittelteil der lawine kommt für
gewöhnlich das meiste gerollt mit
größter buch herunter je weiter weg
davon desto größer sind die
überlebenschancen
zu ihrem glück schützt ein felsvorsprung
die bergsteiger davor unter tonnen von
eis und geröll begraben zu werden
du kannst 20 cm 2 meter oder 20 meter
tief begraben werden je nach lawine
fassungslos klettern die bergsteiger aus
dem zelt das beinahe zu ihrem grab
geworden wäre
ich versuche hilfe zu holen alles
verwüstet
es ist das verheerendste unglück in der
geschichte des everest über 20 tote und
dutzende schwerverletzte müssen per
hubschrauber geborgen werden in der
gesamten himalaya region kommen mehr als
8000 menschen ums leben
[Musik]
wilhelmina bay in der antarktis einem
magneten für wahlbeobachter und
naturliebhaber
im februar 2012 bewundern touristen
einen eisberg vom schlauchboot aus
im sommer können eisberge je nach größe
ein wenig schmelzen und der eisberg hat
auch noch eine hülle die will man sich
doch aus der nähe ansehen
der fällt heute noch zusammen dann
passiert es plötzlich
[Applaus]
ein jahrhundertealter eisberg kollabiert
einfach in sekundenschnelle
in der antarktis gibt es gigantische
mengen an eis dass gletscher kalben und
ins wasser stürzen ist teil eines
natürlichen vorgangs
natürlich aber furcht einflößend das
boot schwankt gefährlich der
touristenführer gibt gas um die gruppe
in sicherheit zu bringen
dabei fliegt ein eisbrocken direkt auf
die kamera zu
wenn solche eisberge solche massen an
eis und schnee ins wasser stürzen lösen
sie flutwellen aus die kleine boot
vielleicht zum kentern bringen können
und da ins wasser zu fallen bedeutet
lebensgefahr
glücklicherweise wird niemand verletzt
und am schluss sagt nur noch die spitze
des eisbergs aus den fluten
wie gut kennen sie sich mit den weißen
riesen in der antarktis aus
[Musik]
satellitendaten zeigen dass die
eisschmelze in teilen der antarktis
jährlich um 18 milliarden tonnen zunimmt
das entspricht einem eiswürfel mit über
vier kilometern kantenlänge
[Musik]
das wird super die alpen an der
französisch-schweizerischen grenze die
abfahrten hier lassen das herz jedes
skifahrers höher schlagen aber im januar
2015 trüben 90 zentimeter neuschnee das
vergnügen
wenn es mehrmals schneit können sich
unterschiedlich dichte schnee lagen
bilden das erhöht das lawinenrisiko
manchmal reicht schon ein skifahrer aus
um ein schneebrett abbrechen zu lassen
und genau das passiert als eine gruppe
von freunden in den noch unberührten
schnee vordringt
der skifahrer mit der helmkamera erkennt
die gefahr aber zu spät
sabine wo ist james er bemerkt dass
einer der freunde fehlt
wo ist james wo ist er
der unter schnee begraben skifahrer ist
mit einem funksender ausgerüstet seine
freunde allerdings nicht jetzt
entscheiden minuten über leben oder tod
als erstes muss man für ein luftloch
sorgen und herausfinden wo oben und
unten ist
ich sehe ihn dann entdeckte skifahrer
den skistock seines freundes der aus dem
schnee rat
der verschüttete hat geistesgegenwärtig
seinen arm samt skistock in die höhe
gereckt
sofort beginnt der helfer zu graben ich
bin bei dir siehst du ihn ja
wo ist sein kopf
wir sind hier kumpel
selbst im leichten pulverschnee dauert
es vier endlose minuten den kopf des
verschütteten frei zu graben damit er
luft bekommt
[Musik]
er friert
fünf personen brauchen fast eine stunde
um ihn komplett zu befreien
jeder der abseits der piste fährt muss
entsprechend ausgebildet seien und die
richtige ausrüstung dabei haben das
entscheidet in so einer situation über
leben oder tod
sind sie winterfest wenn es drauf
ankommt
sieht aus wie sahne die geschlagen wird
was ist das im februar 2015 bahnt sich
eine diesellok mit 4000 ps ihren weg
durch die schneeberge im südosten
kanadas
ich hätte todesangst wenn so ein zug auf
mich zu gast kämen
[Musik]
die lok hat echt was drauf
april 2011 dutzende tornados fegen über
den süden der usa hinweg
im norden alabamas ist eine erste
tornadowarnung herausgegeben worden als
eine frau auf dem weg zur arbeit diese
schockierenden aufnahmen macht ein
tornado der stärke 4 kommt direkt auf
sie zu
im april 2011 hatten wir über 7 100
tornados die wetterbedingungen waren wie
gemacht dafür
als die frau ihr handy zur seite legt
hört man deutlich das heulen der
windhose
sie tut das richtige und duckt sich um
ihren kopf zu schützen da kommt ein
echtes prachtexemplar auf sie zu
während der tornado sich nähert wird das
auto hörbar von trümmerteilen getroffen
dann passiert das unvorstellbare
sie hebt ab
unglaublich
was man nicht sieht sind die vielen
kleinen tornados die um den großen herum
kreisen einer von denen hat sie wohl
erwischt der wagen wird durch die luft
geschleudert
[Musik]
erst nach 15 sekunden landet die frau
wieder auf festem boden
[Musik]
doch vorher kraft der wagen noch in ein
gebäude
wie durch ein wunder überlebt sie
unverletzt
was für ein höllenritt sie hat glück
noch am leben zu sein ich hätte den
rückwärtsgang eingelegt und wer mit
quietschenden reifen abgehauen
die antwort auf diese frage könnte ihnen
eines tages das leben retten
[Musik]
fahren sie nach möglichkeit im rechten
winkel zu tornado spur
falls sie von starkem wind erfasst
werden fahren sie rechts ran und stellen
sie den wagen sicher ab bleiben sie
angeschnallt im auto sitzen und drucken
sie sich vermeiden sie es unter einer
brücke zu halten
juni 2014
der branche er zerstört die ganze stadt
eine gefährliche und äußerst seltene
tornado formation zieht sturmjäger in
den 350 seelen ort bild
kann mich gut erinnern ich stand im
nachrichtenstudio hat mit offenem mund
auf den monitor gestarrt
der sturmjäger fährt ein stück weiter um
besser filmen zu können während der
tornado immer heftiger wird
wenn man das sieht denkt man nur gleich
fährt er mitten rein
man erkennt sogar die komplexe multi
vortex rotation all diese tanzenden
wirbel
plötzlich erscheint in der ferne ein
weiterer traum ado da ist noch ein zwei
riesige tornados der stärke 4 keine zwei
kilometer voneinander entfernt
sowas ist extrem selten
zwillings tornados die fast gleich
aussehen und wie synchron
nebeneinanderher rotieren sie sind
gewaltig und zerstörerisch ein einziges
gewitter kann mehrere tornados
hervorbringen allerdings für gewöhnlich
nacheinander
aus dem tornado können sich kleinere
fortsetze zum boden erstrecken und wenn
die luftströmungen im gewitter stimmen
können sogar zwei tornados direkt
nebeneinander entstehen
zwei menschen kommen ums leben knapp 20
werden verletzt weite teile der stadt
bilder liegen in trümmern
aus der gewitterzelle die die zwillings
tornados hervorgebracht hat entstehen
insgesamt acht tornados im nordosten de
bras gas
zu welcher jahreszeit haben tornados
hochsaison
die meisten tornados treten von
frühlingsanfang bis hochsommer auf sie
können allerdings zu jeder anderen
jahreszeit ständig und überall
zuschlagen
mai 2015 enormen oklahoma riskiert ein
hausbesitzer einen blick aus einem
schutzraum mit dem handy filmt er wie es
im auge eines tornados aussieht
ein tornado der stärke 0 bis 1 fegte in
verbindung mit starkregen durch norman
oklahoma
[Musik]
da fliegt eine schlauch trommel durchs
bild
das zeigt wenn es stürmt sollte man
lieber nicht draußen herumliegen lassen
die sichtweite sinkt gegen null die
windrichtung scheint sich während der
aufnahme zu ändern offenbar zieht der
tornado direkt über den mann hinweg
die situation ist gleich doppelt gefärbt
schwere regenfälle auf völlig
durchnässten boden und dazu tornados
aber die bewohner bleiben unversehrt auf
ihr haus wird nur leicht beschädigt
bei einem stärkeren tornado wäre es für
den hausbesitzer gefährlich geworden als
aus dem schutzraum lobte er hatte
ziemliches glück
[Applaus]
[Musik]
world keller ein farmer aus kansas soll
1928 im herzen eines tornados gewesen
sein er berichtete um ihn herum sei es
totenstill gewesen und ein starker
gasgeruch habe ihm das atmen erschwert
september 2013 in boulder colorado fällt
innerhalb kurzer zeit so viel regen wie
sonst in einem ganzen jahr die folge
heftige überschwemmungen oder
ist ein hochrisiko gebiet in der region
gibt es viele flüsse die leicht über die
ufer treten ein starkregen kann schnell
in einer katastrophe enden
das liegt an der art des bodens um der
lage es gibt viel steiles gelände um die
berghänge wirken wie trichter das alles
führt zum chaos wenn sich dort
gesättigte tropische luft entlädt
die helmkamera eines motorradfahrers
zeigt wie die flut über die straßen
spült da der fahrer die strecke gut
kennt glaubt er dennoch alles im griff
zu haben
da denkt man sich dre doch oben ich bin
auch ein adrenalin-junkie aber manche
sachen lässt man lieber bleiben
jetzt treibst du im fluss das sieht
nicht gut aus
der biker wird von der strömung
mitgerissen
plötzlich kämpft er ums überleben
man sieht ja nicht was unter der
wasseroberfläche los ist da gibt es
verwirbelungen die strömung kann ein
nach unten ziehen
der man klammert sich am ufer fest und
kommt schließlich den reißenden fluten
das war knapp der motorradfahrer
übersteht das schlammbad unverletzt und
findet sogar seine maschine wieder
allerdings dauert es neun tage bis sie
aus dem schlamm geborgen werden kann
in südamerika liegt westlich der alten
einer der trockensten orte der welt die
atacama wüste in chile im märz 2015 wird
sich jedoch nach starken regenfällen
überflutet
anders als hier bei uns ist der boden
völlig ausgedörrt wenn es dort regnet
ist das als wird regen auf einen teller
fallen kippt der tara fließt das wasser
einfach unter
nur zwölf stunden fällt so viel
niederschlag wie in den sieben jahren
zuvor für viele sind das die heftigsten
regenfälle seit 80 jahren
die wassermassen treffen das gebiet wie
ein hurrikan überall trümmer zerstörte
autos das alles gibt es auch bei
hurricanes
das wasser fließt wahrscheinlich mit
rund 15 kilometer pro stunde aber wegen
der höheren dichte wirkt die flut wie
ein tornado der stärke 5 auf alles was
sich ihr in den weg stellt
ungewöhnlich hohe meerestemperaturen
haben zu dem unwetter beigetragen
25 sie lehnen sterben weitere 100 werden
vermisst und tausende in der atacama
region sind obdachlos
juni 2015 in tiflis der hauptstadt
georgiens reißen wassermassen bei einer
überschwemmung zahlreiche autos und
sogar ganze gebäude mit sich
durch tiflis fließt es flüsschen wäre
über den bergen hat sich eine
gewitterzelle gebildet deren
niederschlag sich durch das flusstal
ergossen hat
wenn sich schlamm bei einem erdrutsch
löst fließt er überall hin und in dieser
stadt leben eine million menschen die
sturzflut erreicht auch den zoo er steht
fast vier meter unter wasser
als hätte ein tsunami den zoo getroffen
ziemlich beunruhigend wenn die gehege
wilder tiere völlig verwüstet werden und
sie ums überleben kämpfen
für viele der totale alptraum
tatsächlich wird ein mann von einem
entkommenen tiger getötet die behörden
sehen sich gezwungen einige der
raubtiere zu erlegen 19 menschen kommen
bei der überschwemmung darunter drei
tierpfleger und die hälfte der
ursprünglich 600 tiere verendet in den
fluten oder wird gezielt erschossen
april 2015 an der südamerikanischen
pazifikküste scheint der himmel in
flammen zu stehen zum ersten mal seit
über 40 jahren bricht der vulkan kall
buckow aus
vulkane sind total faszinierend
der vulkanisch bei 200 millionen tonnen
asche über 10 kilometer in die höhe und
windströmungen tragen sie rund um die
welt
manche partikel werden bis zu 20
kilometer hoch in die stratosphäre
geschleudert
noch dazu zucken blitze über den himmel
man sieht nicht oft so viele blitze bei
einem vulkanausbruch
5000 menschen werden im umkreis von 20
kilometern evakuiert
[Musik]
ein ausbruch lässt sich nicht genau
vorhersagen das macht es ziemlich
gefährlich in der nähe eines vulkans zu
wohnen
ein anderer vulkan hat einen der
grössten lavaströme der welt verursacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
2014 filmt eine drohne den ausbruch von
island riesigen vulkanen barbara banga
ferngesteuerte fluggeräte ermöglichen
die erforschung entlegener vulkane wie
diesem aber die faszinierenden aufnahmen
haben ihren preis die drohne fliegt so
nah heran dass die kamera schmilzt
glücklicherweise bleibt die
speicherkarte intakt
im april 2015 breiten sich in sibirien
gefährliche steppen brände aus 5000
helfer sind gegen die flammen im einsatz
die leute denken in den nördlichen
breiten gäbe es keine waldbrände aber
das ist unsinn die flammen gefährden
zahlreiche menschen und tiere
wie rettet man sich wenn man vom feuer
umzingelt ist ich hätte nicht die
leiseste ahnung
das feuer wird vom wind weiter angefacht
und breitet sich so extrem schnell aus
in nur 24 stunden verdoppeln sich die
ausmaße des infernos spanische
autofahrer steuern beim versuch zu
fliehen direkt in das flammenmeer hinein
ich würde weiter fahren bloß nicht
anhalten was dabei raus käme kann man
sich ja denken
plötzlich fängt das heck eines wagens
feuer
das gestrüpp und die trümmer sind sehr
heiß sie bringen sachen zum schmelzen
und können sie sogar entzünden
möglicherweise wurde das feuer von
bauern verursacht die trockenes gras auf
ihren feldern abgebrannt haben wegen
ungewöhnlich hoher temperaturen war die
vegetation so ausgedörrt dass sich der
brand auf über 100.000 hektar land
ausbreiten konnte
september 2013 im norden kaliforniens
eine familie kämpft gegen einen
flächenbrand der vom wind angefacht wird
ein besonders heißer sommer hat die
katastrophe begünstigt
der baum fällt um in diesem teil
kaliforniens herrschten temperaturen von
über 40 grad dazu niedrige
luftfeuchtigkeit
der hausbesitzer versucht verzweifelt
das feuer abzuwehren
er will mit der planierraupe eine
brandschneise schaffen ist vielleicht
drei meter breit es bräuchte aber 30 der
mit der wind keine glut drüber gehen
kann
windböen lassen die flammen meter weit
in die höhe schlagen
bloß weg hier wie sich das feuer verhält
lässt sich aufgrund des windes und der
beschaffenheit der enge überhaupt nicht
vorhersagen
[Musik]
die familie kann sich in letzter sekunde
in sicherheit bringen
zwei missed aber ihr haus fällt in
flammen zum opfer man verliert wofür man
20 30 jahre gearbeitet hat wo die
familie groß geworden ist
los jetzt wir müssen hier weg
man muss einsehen dass die flammen nicht
zu stoppen sind
das feuer wütet auf über 30
quadratkilometern es fordert ein
menschenleben und zerstört 68 häuser
feuer breitet sich mit 10 bis 13
kilometern pro stunde aus aber bei wind
kann es leicht doppelt so schnell werden
erst brennt nur eine kleine fläche dann
der ganze hügel auf dem weg nach oben
umschließt das feuer innerhalb von
minuten ganze siedlungen
[Musik]
wir werden vom blitz getroffen werden
wir nicht
juli 2007 zwei meteorologie studenten
der university of oklahoma filmen von
ihrem balkon aus ein wahres feuerwerk an
blitzen
[Musik]
hast du den
es ist gefährlich sich bei so einem
wetter draußen aufzuhalten
sie verstoßen gegen einer der
wichtigsten sicherheitsregeln überhaupt
jeder sturmjäger wird dir sagen dass
seine größte angst nicht tornados oder
riesen hagel gilt sondern blitzen
so lauten donner habe ich noch nie
gehört das gewitter bringt heftigen
niederschlag mit sich und windböen mit
über 100 kilometern pro stunde
da noch einer
es blitzt wie verrückt aber sie scheinen
weit entfernt oder
sagt meiner familie dass ich sie liebe
sowas habe ich auch mal erlebt ganz
ehrlich das mache ich bestimmt nie
wieder wenn wir draußen drehen behalte
ich die blitze ganz genau im auge
die studenten sind so nah am
einschlagsort dass sie ein kribbeln im
nacken und in den zehn spüren seitdem
haben sie vermutlich mehr respekt vor
dem spannungsgeladenen naturschauspiel
schon ironisch die beiden studieren
immerhin das wetter
wissen sie wie blitze entstehen
zunächst braut sich ein gewitter
zusammen
in der gewitterzelle prallen hagelkörner
aufeinander die atmosphäre lädt sich auf
negativ und positiv geladene teilchen
entstehen das muss ich irgendwie
entladen und
dann zog der blitz
[Musik]
in marana/arizona gelingt einem
fotografen dieser glückstreffer ein
regenbogen direkt neben einem blitz
verursacht durch einen sogenannten micro
gast das foto erobert das netz im sturm
in den sumpf landschaften entlang des
golfs von mexiko können sich von jetzt
auf gleich reißenden gewässer ihren weg
bahnen und menschenleben bedrohen
jetzt kommt die sturmflut rein
als hurrikan katrina im august 2005 auf
die küste trifft verfolgen einige
sturmjäger das geschehen im golfsport
mississippi von einem hotel aus dass
keine 250 meter vom strand entfernt ist
trainer traf mississippi besonders hart
mit der heftigsten sturmflut und dem
stärksten wind mississippi und der süden
von alabama waren am schlimmsten
betroffen
die sturmjäger sind mitten in einem
hurrikan der kategorie 3
ein hurrikan ist viel verheerender als
ein tornado dieser sturm hat hunderte
kilometer entlang der küste verwüstet
von lousiana bis rüber nach mississippi
und alabama
zunächst drücken die äußeren winde in
katrinas fall die schwächeren winde das
wasser richtung ufer da steckt
konstanter druck dahinter
in der lobby unseres hotels treiben
möbel im wasser
die fluten spülen sogar ein auto gegen
die eingangstüren des hotels
30 cm hohes wasser kann rund 700
kilogramm tragen wenn das wasser 60 cm
hoch steht reicht das also schon aus um
ein auto wegzuschwimmen
bei dem auto macht mir am meisten sorge
dass sich durch einen kurzschluss das
benzin entzünden könnte
draußen herrschen windgeschwindigkeiten
von 200 kilometern pro stunde
das erdgeschoss steht komplett unter
wasser
der welt lässt das wasser nicht wieder
abfließen dadurch steigt es immer weiter
und dann setzen die richtig starken
winde ein
[Musik]
der wasserpegel steigt auf über 8 meter
an und die fluten erreichen den ersten
stock des hotels
eine acht meter hohe sturmflut das ist
der bisher höchste wert in den usa sie
hat die kraft eines bulldozers
[Musik]
hunderte menschen kamen in mississippi
ums leben weil sie sich nicht
rechtzeitig in sicherheit gebracht haben
fast zehn jahre später im april 2015
wird entlang der golfküste eine tornado
warnung ausgesprochen in new orleans
fallen hagelkörner so gross wie
golfbälle
da zogen mehrere gewitterzellen in einer
linie aufgereiht durch sichtbar als
bogen airshow durch starke winde wird
die gewitterlinie bogenförmig während
sie vor anrollt
um 10 uhr 30 wird es stockdunkel und die
straßenlaternen schalten sich ein
wenn ein sturm immer heftiger wird halte
ich für gewöhnlich an sobald die
scheibenwischer den regen nicht mehr
bewältigen können
es regnet so heftig dass dieser fahrer
kaum noch sieht was vor ihm auf der
straße passiert es fehlen 50 mm regen
die windgeschwindigkeit erreichte 110 km
pro stunde sehr ungewöhnlich zu dieser
tageszeit
eine windböe knickt einen strommasten
[Musik]
strommasten sind über die stromleitungen
miteinander verbunden fällt einer um
könnten weitere wie dominosteine folgen
dieses video zeigt zwei meiner größten
ängste als sturmjäger zum einen von
einem strommast zerquetscht zu werden
zum anderen von abgerissenen leitungen
gegrillt zu werden
der fahrer und sein wagen bleiben
unversehrt aber nicht weit entfernt
liegt der sturm vier zugwaggons samt
einem dutzend container von einer brücke
wie gut kennen sie sich mit stürmen aus
nah am boden verlangsamt reibung den
wind je weiter oben desto größer die
windgeschwindigkeit
mai 2015 nach san antonio im süden von
texas nachdem mehrere stürme in diesem
monat bereits 50 zentimeter regen
gebracht haben hat sich ein ruhiger bach
in einen reißenden strom verwandelt
[Musik]
allein am samstag zuvor waren fast 80
liter pro quadratmeter regen gefallen
daher gerieten viele bäche und flüsse
außer kontrolle und traten über die ufer
nach mehreren jahren dürre waren die
böden texas völlig verhärtet
das wasser versickert nicht wie sonst
üblich dadurch kommt es zu
schwerwiegenden überschwemmungen
er muss daraus ein älterer mann bleibt
mitten in den fluten mit seinem fahrzeug
liegen er hat versucht die wassermassen
zu durchqueren
manchmal sieht man wasser auf der straße
und stellt sich auch da kann ich durch
fahren ich bin doch kein weichei
wasser auf der straße ist immer
gefährlich egal wie hoch es steht wenn
der reifen zur hälfte im wasser steht
ist es eindeutig zu tief
und fassbar dass da jemand drin ist
schließlich gelingt es den fahrer aus
seinem wagen zu bergen
der mann hatte riesenglück viele
menschen kommen in genau solchen
situationen ums leben
der mai 2015 ist in texas einer der
regenreichsten monate seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnung
haben sie sich je gefragt was den geruch
von regen verursacht in dieser aufnahme
sind kleine aerosol wolken zu erkennen
die von einem regentropfen freigesetzt
werden wenn er auf den boden trifft wie
sprudel blasen im sektglas
wissenschaftlern zufolge setzten sie den
spezifischen ehrt geruchsfrei
manchmal will man einfach nur die
schönheit der natur bewundern und sich
von ihrer eindrucksvollen kraft
inspirieren lassen
was für ein anblick das könnte ich mir
stundenlang ansehen
besonders reizvoll wird das ganze aus
dem all
seit anfang der 60er jahre haben nasa
astronauten über 1,5 millionen fotos vom
planeten erde gemacht
[Applaus]
seit beginn der satelliten zeitalters
verstehen wir viel besser wie
verschiedene wetterlagen zustande kommen
unser planet ist einfach spektakulär das
versetzt einen in ehrfurcht
ob weltraumfahrzeuge oder satelliten im
orbit ihre bilder eröffnen meteorologen
neue blickwinkel
wir bewegen uns außerhalb der
stratosphäre und in der mesosphäre wir
blicken vom weltall aus auf die erde und
die bilder sind einfach atemberaubend
wie einst ein astronaut der apollo 8
mission sagte wir haben den langen weg
zurückgelegt um den mond zu erforschen
und unsere wichtigste entdeckung ist die
erde
die erde muss sich nicht auf hübschen
oder besonders zu recht machen sie
braucht weder lippenstift noch botox
nackt und natürlich ist sie wunderschön
eine nasa studie legt nahe dass die
stürme in den usa mit der zunehmenden
luftverschmutzung auf der anderen seite
des pazifiks zusammenhängen könnten
diese computeranimation stellt partikel
in der luft da sulfate vom verbrennen
fossiler brennstoffe in weiß rauch von
waldbränden in grün wüstenstaub in rot
und sprühnebel von zyklonen in blau
zurück auf der erde
orgons atemberaubenden küste ist ein
gutes beispiel für faszinierend schöne
wetter kapriolen
der pazifik ist eine echte naturgewalt
mit unglaublicher kraft
die wellen dort sind der wahnsinn vor
allem an einer felsküste wie in oregon
die energie im pazifischen ozean ist
unvergleichlich selbst stürme im 9000
kilometer entfernung sorgen an der
us-küste für hohe wellen
vor allem im winter kommt es zu starken
stürmen
das zieht uns an wir wollen die elemente
spüren teil der natur sein und mit ihr
verbunden fühlen etwas schöneres gibt es
nicht
wie gut kennen sie sich eigentlich mit
eishöhlen aus
selbst an einem wolkigen tag sorgt die
sonne für eine spektakuläre lichtshow in
den sogenannten kristall höhlen
unterhalb des isländischen gletscher
vatnajökull
im frühjahr und sommer ist es zu
gefährlich sie zu besichtigen aber im
winter ist der abstieg sicher dann ist
das eis in den höhlen stabil genug
[Musik]
beeindruckende wetterphänomene bekommt
man auch in michigan nader great lakes
zu sehen ich bezeichne die great lakes
immer als natürliches wetter labor
michigans obere halbinsel ist einer der
kältesten orte der erde durch den
sogenannten lake effect fallen dort
jährlich bis zu sieben meter schnee
wenn kaltluft ausbrüche vom nordpol oder
sibirien geradewegs über kanada
hinwegziehen lanken sie dort
hier ist auch einer der besten orte um
den nachthimmel zu beobachten
es gibt nicht viele menschen kaum
industrie und wenig straßenlampen
deshalb sieht man den sternenhimmel in
seiner ganzen pracht
genau wie die leuchtenden farben der
aurora borealis auch polarlichter
genannt ein geschenk der fernen sonne
bei sonneneruptionen wird plasma
ausgestoßen dass mit der erdatmosphäre
interagiert und dabei gase ionisiert das
sorgt für diese fantastischen farben
wenn man weit genug im norden ist sieht
man die polarlichter durch die
atmosphäre ziehen
wegen solcher anblicke wird man
meteorologe das ist einfach fesseln
ich betrachte das als wissenschaftler
und doch vergesse ich nie was für ein
wunderschönes perfektes kunstwerk das
ist
[Musik]